c'est aujourd'hui qu'a réellement
commencé le festival de cannes la grande
bretagne ouvre le feu avec un film de
marc et cani escales un jeune auteur
polonais un film qui s'intitule un autre
pays et puis un nouveau bergman l'a
répété après la répétition
ceci pour la sélection officielle mais
ce que le public attend avec impatience
c'est la projection à 23 heures du film
d'andrzej zulawski la femme publique
avec valérie kaprisky francis huster et
lambert wilson
un film choc ça veut dire quoi choquer
il n'y a pas de soldats à l'entrée d'une
salle qui vous pousse à la force des
baïonnettes pour aller voir un film
vous êtes très libre d'entrée de sortir
je ne vois pas c'est assez quelque chose
de très consenti on est prévenus
d'avancé on vous prévient même
terriblement fort pour un film je ne
pense pas qu'il est tellement choquant
rio le loulou là c'est très choquant
donc vous êtes plutôt archi prévenu jeu
j'aurais plus un peu ce cette notion de
choquer pas choquée moi ce qui me choque
c'est l'ennui et la bêtise